my current role demands a lot of
understanding of data and interpretation
of it
and i wanted to be self-dependent in
understanding data so i decided to
pursue further studies from a reputed
university from us hi this is anivant
vari
i belong from eastern part of india
kolkata
i have been placed in bombay because of
my professional career
today i laid a large team of people
having across different functions and
geographies in the bank i initially
dependent on our business analytic team
but after my recent completion of
program i'm quite self-reliant and i can
able to reinterpret data's of my own
when i talk about simply learn i really
comment on their quality of faculties
and experiential learning it is a one
year intensive program with well
designed curriculum
with a blend of
theoretical and applied courses
i really enjoyed the live sessions
delivered by the global practitioners
and class interactions within my diverse
patch
we also had practical labs ibm
hackathons and industry-based projects
hello i am elena alvarez's
papa has always been very dedicated to
his work and we are all proud of him for
what he has been able to achieve
after seeing him upskill i as a health
line front worker i am thinking about
taking up courses online and building
stronger
i have high regards for simply learn the
kind of services and the quality of
training important to me during the
period of the course with added skills
in my profile
doing data science from purdue
university
i am confident that i will be doing
better at my workplace delivering a
quality projects
invest in yourself and give yourself
time to grow coffee 19 has affected all
of us
during this
unprecedented time but one should
remember
success cannot be locked down